All right, you're done.
Let's take a look at the solution.
Delete is actually pretty straightforward.
Note that once again
we have almost useless parameters.
S actually refers to our selection
while our strings here
are actually our selection Rs.
One little trickiness in delete is that
if you actually put no selection in,
it'll delete all the rows.
I still want to make sure we
notify the change.
I've done the slide optimization here.
It would be fine
to just notify the change always,
but I've decided
if no rows have been deleted,
then we should bother not notifying.
Unless the selection is null,
in which case we deleted all the rows,
but again, it would be fine to just
use notify change here
even if no rows are actually deleted.
After all, the intention was that rows
would be deleted.
Once again, let's take pity on someone
who might have to maintain your code,
and change these default parameter names
to something more useful
like selection and selectionargs.
Other than that,
update looks almost exactly like delete.
Once again, we are returning
the number of rows
impacted by the update,
and we don't bother notifying
if no rows were impacted.
Now that we've finished
writing update and delete
we can go back to test provider
and add some tests.
First, let's remove test delete.db,
the last test that doesn't depend
on the provider.
Instead, let's have a test that deletes
all the records and checks to make sure
they're actually deleted.
Remember, passing a null query
actually deletes
all of the records in a table.
So this is really straightforward,
just passing nulls.
Since we're depending
on the database for our deletes,
it's not all that particularly important
that we actually test the delete functions,
although it would be nice to add that later on.
The reason we'd want to add it
is to make sure
that our constraints are valid.
And once we're done doing the deletes,
we check to make sure
that there are no rows left.
Note that we have to delete weather entry
before we delete location entry
because you've got constraints
in the database that prevent weather entry
from existing if location entries
do not also exist
and would also prevent
the deletion of those entries.
So let's check to see
whether that actually works.
All right, that passes. Good news.
Now we can add the same test
to the end to make sure
we can delete all of the rows
at the end and it still works.
And as you can see, they still pass.
So now we know we've deleted records
before and after running tests.
Now let's try that update.
We'll do just an update of the location.
Again, let's start by deleting all records
and inserting a record that we want to update.
One of the nice things
about content values
is you can actually copy them
using a copy constructor.
After that, we can add the ID
we want to update
and then put the name of the city
we want to update it to.
In this case, from North Pole
to Santa's Village.
And then, finally, we call update.
Assert that we've actually
updated exactly one record
as we'd expect, and then do a query on that,
validating our cursor,
making sure our update actually works.
And then finally, we close our cursor.
It all looks pretty good.
And let's see that it actually runs,
and does the right thing.
And our tests pass.
So, we've now proved that we
can update, delete, insert, and query,
and all this is fully tested.
In other words, the bones of our application
are finished, just waiting to attach our UI.
Let's go through and attach some of our UI.